hey guys what's going on welcome to the
eleventh tkinter with python three
tutorial video in this video we're going
to just continue working on our
application we have a few changes that
we want to make to kind of structure of
our code but otherwise we're ready to
actually modify this script so right now
we just load up and we've got a live
grab now these are actual prices look at
that Manchu that pretty volatile um
anyway we got this live graph that is
working but the next things that we want
if you remember the original application
we had a whole you know main menu
basically up here where you could choose
a whole bunch of options and stuff like
that so now we want to do in this video
in the subsequent videos one set up the
structure for all those options in our
main menu and then once we've got the
structure there we'll actually build the
backend to support that structure and
you'll see that the the methodology that
we use here is going to be fairly
similar to the methodology that I've
used in the past as far as building a
large program so building large programs
can be really daunting but the way that
I've kind of worked around how to build
a large program is basically I write the
program how I would like to be able to
write the program basically so so I
structure everything the way I'd like it
to be and I say like if I if I want to
call a function I just make up the name
of the function right then and there
with the understanding of what I want
that function to eventually do and then
later I'll come back to it in our case
we're basically to do the same thing
where we kind of build the backend first
because that's that that's the real
challenging part and then later on you
can build the function to satisfy those
needs and you can build the function
really the exact same way kind of almost
backwards you know you build the
completed product and then you kind of
plug everything in at the end it
hopefully make a little bit more sense
as we go through it if you've followed
some of my other tutorials then you
should probably be somewhat familiar
with my my structuring but anyway um the
first things first that I want to do is
no longer do we want to do figure size
at all what might that plot Lib is going
to do in this tkinter application is
based on the rules that we set in our
tkinter application map that lives
actually going to
automatically scale to the size of our
application and what's happening here is
actually our application is scaling tor
tkinter window I mean our matplotlib
graph we don't really want that so what
we're going to go ahead and do is tribe
here we're going to do from matplotlib
import pie plot pie plot as PLT then f
is just going to equal figure empty
parameters we're not going to have DPI
or figure size just boom empty
parameters and then now we want to go to
the very very bottom of our script here
basically right where we've got app
equals cVTC app and what you want to add
here is you just do app dot geometry
geometry' and here we can specify the
size of our application so in our case
we're going to do 1280 by 720 now if
you're happening to follow along this
tutorial and you don't have that high of
a resolution then choose something else
you know 800 by 600 should fit everybody
I don't think anybody's following along
on a cell phone so that should be fine
fine enough you can also feel free to do
you know 1920 by 1080 or whatever if you
want it really doesn't matter I like
this size I think it's a good size so
I'm going to go with it anybody who has
a smaller resolution though it will you
know scrunch up the application to fit
so just keep that in mind but when it
scratches up the application stuff does
get kind of squished away especially
buttons in the tkinter applications so
the navigation buttons for the graph
will disappear and any other buttons on
the page will disappear so just keep
that in mind and so uh now what we're
ready to do is we're ready that go ahead
and add a main menu bar so scroll on up
to see a BDC app and this is where we
put a lot of the stuff that pertains
just to the app in general that is going
to be on every single page and then
later on you'll see that most of the
functionality that we write is actually
going to go with in the animation
function because that's where how the
graphed
Jews and basically anytime we want to
query a database or we're trying to
query or maybe send in stuff we're
actually going to use animate for this
but we'll get to that so within here
we're going to go ahead and after this
you know block of four containers we're
just going to come down here and before
self dot frames although it could be
after it wouldn't really matter and this
is where we're going to add some code so
first we're going to say menu bar and
menu bar is going to equal TK dot
capital M menu and then container so
basically it's a menu where are we going
to put the menu we're putting in the
container so the next thing that we're
going to have is now now that's the menu
bar now we want a file menu right so in
this application here's our menu bar and
then we have a file where we go new or
close or exit whatever as if close and
exit is that significantly different
anyway
file menu we'll call it equals TK . menu
and then you say what menu does that is
it going to it's going to the menu bar
and then we're going to say tear-off
equals zero now I'll explain what
tear-off means in a little bit but
basically let's see all of these are
tear-off and you can even see it's this
like dotted line so we can click that
usually yeah so we can click that and we
can it becomes it's like own little
window of options and we can use that
within our application as well so say
for example we're going to have a
trading tab soon and we will go to trade
and then we can actually make that its
own window and then you can hit buy sell
buy buy buy sell or whatever you need to
do so you can make really quick trades
if you wanted to so we'll close out of
that but for the file menu I really
don't see the point why you would tear
it off but I mean you could add that as
an option on every window it really
doesn't matter but for now we'll just
say tear-off equals zero and then the
next thing we're going to do is go file
menu dot add underscore a command and
this basically adds an option to the
menu so first we're going to say label
and label is going to equal we're going
to have this one call Save Settings
pretty soon we're going to allow users
to basically save a bunch of settings
like what is the timeframe of the data
what exchange do they care about that
kind of stuff
it may be eventually will allow them to
save their API information the problem
there is you'll have to encrypt it and
decrypt it and to decrypt it you have to
obviously have the public private key
stuff and then pulling that we just have
to make sure that's totally safe and
secure on their computer I think I'd
rather just have them input it and then
any sort of transmission is already
encrypted anyway so I'll let the user
kind of decide but eventually we might
do that both save settings mostly for
like exchange timeframes stuff like that
and then we're going to have this since
this doesn't exist yet and actually it
doesn't even exist in the current
version as I'm filming this there's
obviously the current version I showed
in the first video that we still don't
have that and so like say you want to
add something there because you really
want that in your program but you don't
you know have it yet what I'm gonna have
it do is it's going to hold a place but
we're gonna have the command B equal to
lambda Poland and then pop-up message
will be the function and then the
message is not supported just yet
okay and so this is a function popup
message we have not defined pop-up
message so we definitely want to have
that function but they will probably do
that in the next video but obviously
that's a pretty useful function so if
you followed like my PI game tutorial
for example sometimes you want to pop up
text to the screen so you want to have
just a function that does that you
wouldn't want to do that yourself every
time you needed to send a message to the
screen I think that's what I called it
message to screen so here we'll have a
universal kind of popup message any time
we want to show a pop-up message we just
do puppet message throw the text through
it and that's a pop-up so here's an
example of some functionality that I
would like we don't have it yet but this
is how I'd like it to act it'll be a
function and you just pass through the
string that you want
pop-up done so you know what's coming
now that we've done that we're gonna go
file menu dot ad underscore separator
separate tour sounds about right
that just adds a bar um like this like
you've got these bar between path and
save that's like a little bar it's a
little divider kind of to um because if
you don't have it there you know you can
imagine without that divider there's
like so many options here you might get
kind of lost this is too many so it's
sort of highway to organize so add
separator and then we can do file menu
dot and uh underscore commands now and
this one will be label equals exit and
then here we don't need lamda we just do
command equals quit done and done
finally we can do we need to add the
menu bar or the file menu to menu bars
so so far we've basically done all this
in the backend we've defined basically
what file menu is but we haven't shown
any you know we haven't placed it
anywhere so now we're going to place it
to the menu bar so minibar dot add
underscore cascade and this one is going
to be label equals whoops okay that's
gonna take forever
label it equals file so that'll be our
file and then we're going to say the
menu Wow menu equals file menu why I
really want it to be many found menu uh
and that's it so now uh the only last
thing that we need to do is TK dot TK
notice the capital T and the second one
dot config and then we're gonna say self
and then menu B equals menu bar just
like that now we're going to see that
this creates a slight conflict uh with
our ICO so like when we go like this I
didn't do it just yet okay well soon
anyway so hit OK and cool so here's our
application file we've got save settings
and exit here we're still updating on
and I think every 2,000 milliseconds so
two seconds so we'll scroll down at the
very bottom here and so our every second
let's do five seconds for now in the
future what we want to do is we want to
thread this application so when that
graph is updating its not freezing the
entire application so that'll be for a
video way down the road but that will
definitely be necessary for this this
application so we've got file now we can
hit exit and it does want to exit it's
just it launches into the shell and I
won't hit okay so so that's that with a
video 11 we're going to keep adding
basically all that with the file menu
options and the coming videos and then
after that we'll start adding in the
functionality so stay tuned for that
where we add all the options if you guys
have any questions or comments on this
specific video feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the spoiler
subscriptions and until next time